advertencia de contenido a continuación
se habla del suicidio y de ideas
suicidas si estás en crisis o piensas en
el suicidio llama a una de las
siguientes organizaciones
jubilee presenta
invitamos a una conversación sobre el
suicidio y la salud mental a seis
desconocidos que intentaron suicidarse
los medios retratan con precisión la
salud y el suicidio
321 ya
no creo que lo hagan todo el tiempo
porque pueden suceder muchas cosas con
cualquier tipo de enfermedad mental lo
que hace que sea un problema cuando
intentas explicarlo a alguien porque
piensan o como en 13 razones y si no
siempre es así no siempre es así a veces
romantizar sí sí el suicidio y la
depresión en los medios y es algo muy
extraño porque hay algunas
enfermedades mentales que se ven como
moda o atractivas y como la ansiedad
especialmente con twitter y cosas así
todo el mundo habla de ello todos
twittean sobre ello no es una moda es un
problema real con el que la gente vive
los medios no muestran personas como yo
soy una mujer lesbiana negra y el
lidiado con la depresión durante mucho
tiempo he tenido pensamientos suicidas
lo intenté así que al no tener esa
representación es difícil empatizar
creo que los
y medios no lo retratan correctamente
pero también creo que están en buen
camino no es bueno ahora pero está
mejorando creo mi familia entiende
porque quería acabar con mi vida
la primera vez que lo intente fue en la
secundaria y fue algo comprensible para
mi madre y mi hermana porque estábamos
pasando por un divorcio desagradable así
que cuando sucedió entendieron que eso
fue lo que me llevó a ello y luego hace
dos años me drogaron y me agredieron y
esa mañana después de que me encontrarán
fue algo tan traumático que mi madre
salió y yo me fui al balcón recuerdo que
rompí a llorar porque pensé que me iba a
lanzar por él no ven aquí
tranquila y ya no llores
así que creo que tuve la suerte de tener
una familia muy comprensiva con lo que
yo estaba pasando
siento que mi familia no lo entendía
muchos todavía no saben lo que ocurrió
en mi pasado e intentaron agredirle y
vivían con mi mejor amiga ella no lo
sabía nadie sabía no estaba manejando
internamente y ahora que más o menos lo
saben me hubiera gustado que hablaran
conmigo que hicieran preguntas porque
estaba en la universidad sola lidiando
con eso y nadie sabía en mi familia
mis padres son inmigrantes
mi madre era refugiada todos en mi
familia tuvieron problemas de salud
mental y estrés postraumático nunca
hablamos de ello creo que la enfoque era
asegurarse de encajar de conseguir un
buen trabajo de sobrevivir asegúrate de
que la gente te vea como ya sabes
estadounidense a mi familia le costó
mucho incluso entender que tenía
problemas de salud mental
porque pensaban que me iba muy bien en
la escuela y que tenía amigos que veía
todo el tiempo como puedes tener
depresión yo solo no hablo de eso con mi
familia cuando les dije a mis hermanas
que vendrían preguntaron de qué trata y
yo dije del suicidio y ellas dijeron oye
lo hiciste y yo
en realidad no quería morir
cada vez que pasó por una etapa
depresiva solo quiero que alguien me
contenga y es por eso que no creo que
realmente quiera morir lo que yo quiero
lo que yo quiero es vivir pero es muy
difícil hacerlo cada momento que pasaba
yo estaba más y más listo para ver a mi
creador lo veía como la salida más fácil
ir a un lugar que no pudieran
encontrarme y estaría bien no sé cómo me
encontraron de alguna manera mi amigo
tuvo un presentimiento y de repente
la policía comenzó a llamarme por la
ventana de mi auto
fui al extremo cuando quería hacerlo a
mi hermana me rogaba que fuera al médico
que le dijera a alguien y yo era muy
insistente como no quiero
así que en esos momentos
si definitivamente quería morir pero era
porque no conocía otra solución de
definitivamente quería terminar con todo
en ese momento estaba lista y me aseguré
de ir a un lugar donde no pudieran
encontrarme al pensar en ese momento en
que estaba en ese arroyo y en todo lo
que ocurría me siento contenta de
haberme levantado y alejado tuve una
especie de epifanía cuando estaba allí
perdiendo la conciencia de que mi vida
es valiosa
el suicidio es egoísta
321 ya
creo que es muy egoísta es una decisión
que tomas tú solo tampoco tienes muy en
cuenta a los miembros de tu familia a
tus amigos y creo que los efectos de que
te suicides y dejes atrás a tus amigos
ya tu familia podrían hacer que alguno
de ellos también lo haga mi madre estaba
pasando por un divorcio justo en la
época en que yo intenté
suicidarme
y me dijo que ella también pensó en ello
y que quería hacerlo pero que cuando me
vio pasar por eso sabía que no podía
matarse podría ser egoísta
por las otras personas afectadas
entiendo tu punto pero también la
primera vez que lo intente en mi mente
esa era la opción que haría todo más
fácil para mi familia e incluso la
segunda vez volví a pensar lo mismo
porque en mi mente mi familia no quería
a alguien que drogaron y agredieron eso
es una gran carga que llevar así que no
quería imponerles esa carga tan grande
además de la carga financiera pero
míranos a todos todos pensamos que era
nuestra opción pensamos que ese era el
camino a seguir y después vimos los
beneficios de sobrevivir y no tener que
estar muertos y por eso me moví porque
estoy tan de acuerdo con todo lo que
dijiste y también estoy de acuerdo
contigo sobre la situación familiar y
pensar en tu familia y en la gente que
te quiere hace poco me reencontré con mi
padre biológico si hubiera acabado con
mi vida a los 16 eso no habría ocurrido
él me habría encontrado y recibido la
noticia tu hija se suicidó a los 16 así
que ese aspecto me hace sentir que sí
que es egoísta porque todavía hay gente
que ni siquiera conozco que me quiere
estoy de acuerdo contigo en que el
suicidio puede ser egoísta porque es un
trauma enorme para mucha gente pero
cuando yo pasé por ese momento lo que
más bien lo que más me frustró fue que
la gente no quiere que mueran quieren
que viva pero no sé cómo voy a vivir
porque no sabía
si podía empezar la transición médica y
sé que las personas trans en coreano
tienen empleo como voy a conseguir un
trabajo necesito mucho apoyo para seguir
viviendo pero era muy difícil
encontrarlo soy una persona feliz
321 ya
creo que una vez fui muy infeliz y muy
oscura por dentro pero me propuse ser
amigable y extrovertida
ahora soy genuinamente feliz porque he
trabajado muy duro trabajo mi salud
mental y también mi salud física y ser
feliz para mí es sentirse uno con uno
mismo que a veces es estar solo lo cual
está bien siento que la gente ve eso
cómo estás solo todo el tiempo te
excluye a ti mismo no estoy tomando ese
espacio para mí para ser feliz para mí
la felicidad es mucha presión
no quiero medirme con una sola emoción
siento que hay un espectro de
sentimientos molestia alegría también
depresión para mí yo yo no necesito
estar en un estado constante creo que
cuando hablamos de felicidad se confunde
porque creo que en realidad decimos
estás bien y para mí es diferente me
entristece mucho estar aquí porque sé
que decepcionará a mucha gente porque
todos quieren la felicidad para mí a
veces siento que tengo que ser feliz
porque tengo que cumplir los deseos de
esas personas pero en realidad no es eso
se supone que es por mi bien
también es como luchar con un montón de
cosas como ser trans srl
un extranjero tratando de inmigrar a
estados unidos- problemas familiares
entonces está bien no estar bien
seguimos siendo más forzado a ser feliz
está bien si me hubieras preguntado hace
un mes habría estado ahí contigo si hay
altibajos pero la semana pasada fue una
buena semana para mí pero hace un mes
habría estado allí todo mejor
creo que en esta frase todo mejora hay
un eslogan que viene después pero lleva
tiempo
no te curas de inmediato a veces estarás
en ese lugar oscuro y tienes que
aguantar y encontrar esa fuerza de
voluntad dentro de ti y a veces es muy
difícil siento que algo que me dijeron
mucho al crecer fue que la vida no
mejora sino que empeora y todo eso pero
claro que mejora están equivocados toma
esos riesgos ten fe en tus habilidades
empuja hasta donde puedas eso es lo que
he hecho los últimos tres años y
si mejora siento que para mí estoy en
una posición de privilegio porque si
mejoro para mí
tuve acceso a recursos tenía seguro
médico así que pude ver a un terapeuta y
tengo un trabajo así que tengo
estabilidad financiera yo no creo que
todos tengan eso no creo que tengan la
misma suerte
estoy en este lado justo aquí creo que
el tiempo lo cura todo antes dije que no
era feliz pero comparado con donde
estaba cuando intenté suicidarme
he mejorado mucho no estoy en ese estado
mental profundo y oscuro y aun si quiero
vivir todavía lucho con ello pero no
quiero morir y eso es algo creo que eso
es lo que importa nuestra sociedad está
tan empeñada en que tienes que mejorar
bueno todo en rápidamente si tienes que
mejorar rápido o al menos actuar como si
lo estuvieras si no es así está bien si
te sientes mal pero mientras salgas de
eso y te tomes tu tiempo y hagas
necesitas eso es lo que importa me das
un abrazo que sí
todo mejora chicos segundo mucho
conocerlo
[Risas]
eso fue agradable si estás en crisis o
piensas en el suicidio llama a una de
las siguientes organizaciones
jubilee vive intensamente